china is a specific problem and
opportunity for every company pretty
much every company because they are a
dominating force both in their domestic
market as well as their offshore market
and I think a you have to take China
seriously and China is a very nuanced
environment that many of us don't
understand completely yet and I think
the way you do well in new environments
is to experiment right you just don't go
in thinking you know at all what you do
is you go in and experiment and some of
the most successful experiments so far
and China have been going in and
creating joint venture relationships
with Chinese partners where there's a
50-50 relationship or 51-49 and you
learn how to operate in this nuanced
environment and be successful the
opportunity in China is massive but I
think again companies have to be
cautious around you know where there's
great opportunity there's also great
risk and I think you have to not go in
blindly but you have to go in in stages
and I think you have to experiment
through each level of those stages in
order to successfully make it to the
next stage and you see companies for
example in the computer business you
know one of our domestic large computer
manufacturers has gone in they they they
do engineering in China they build in
China and they sell in China and they've
been certified you know with the highest
level of certification for a non chinese
company right so they can supply the
domestic market and I think you know
those sorts of things really matter you
have to go in and become part of the
culture become part of the fabric and
and and lend yourself to that we are
just making boxes and shipping them to
China what we're doing is creating you
know thought leadership and we're
creating you know design centers and
engineering excellence the higher-order
aspects of the role and then we get the
opportunity to sell into the domestic
market it's it I mean the thing about
China that's really hard is that you
know is that you know they can decide
that you're uninvited right and then
they become your worst you know then
they can become one of your greatest
competitor
so I think that's why the experimental
piece is really important so going to
step by step by step and using joint
ventures is a powerful way to sort of
gain entry and gain knowledge on how to
be successful